welcome back so i was trying to rush and
and finish a problem in the last two
minutes of video and i realized that's
just bad uh teaching because i end up
rushing so this was a problem we were
going to work on and you'll see a lot of
these when they just want to become
familiar with you know
the variables in the in the gravity in
the newton's law of gravitation so i
said that there's two planets one is
earth
and you see now i have time to draw
things
so that's earth and then there's small
earth and small earth
well maybe i'll just call it the small
planet don't just we don't get confused
it's green
showing that there's probably life on
that planet
let's say it has half the radius and
half the mass
so if you think about it's probably a
lot denser than earth and that's that's
a good problem to think about how much
denser is it right because if you have
half the radius your volume is much more
than uh it's much less than one half but
i don't want to go into that now that's
something for you to think about but my
question is what fraction if i'm
standing on the surface of this so the
same person so sal
if i'm on earth
what fraction
is the pull when i'm on
this small green planet
so what is the pull on me on earth
well it's just going to be
so
the my weight on earth the force on
earth
is going to be equal to the
gravitational constant
times my mass mass of
well i already use so mass of me
so m sub m
times the mass of earth
divided by what we learned in the last
video divided by the distance between me
and the center of the mass of earth
really my center of mass in the center
mass of earth that's essentially just
you know
the distance between the surface of the
earth and i i'd like to think that i'm
not short but it's negligible between my
center of mass and the surface so we'll
just consider the radius of the earth
so we divided by the radius of the earth
squared
so what's using these same variables
what's going to be the force on on this
other planet so the force on the other
planet this green planet i'll do it in
green
force on and we're calling it the small
planet
it equals what it equals the
gravitational constant again
and my mass doesn't change when i go
from one planet to another
right
its mass now is what we the mass of this
it's we would write an m sub s here
right this is the small planet and we we
wrote right here that's half the mass of
earth so i'll just write that so it's
one half the mass of earth
and what's its radius what's the radius
now
i could just write the radius of the
small planet squared but i'll say well
we know it's one half the radius of
earth so let's put that in there
so one half the radius of earth
we have to square it let's see what this
simplifies to this equals
so we have a we can take this one half
here
one half
g
mass of me times mass of earth
over what's one half squared it's 1 4
over
1 4
radius of earth squared and what's one
half divided by 1 4.
well 1 4 goes into one-half two times
right or another we could think about is
if you have a fraction in the
denominator when you put in the
numerator you flip it and it becomes
four so four times one-half is two
either way that's just
math
so the force on the small planet is
going to be equal to one half divided by
one-fourth is two
times
g
mass of me
times mass of earth divided by the
radius of earth squared and if we look
up here
this
is the same thing as this
right
it's identical
so we know that the the force
that applied to me when i'm the surface
of the small planet is actually two
times
the force applied on earth when i go to
earth
and that's something interesting to
think about because you might have said
initially wow you know gravity uh the
mass of the object matters a lot in
gravity the more mass of the object the
the more it's going to
pull on me but
what we see here is that actually no
when i'm on the surface of this smaller
planet it's pulling even harder on me
and and why is that well because i'm
actually closer to its center of mass
and as we talked about earlier in this
video this this object is probably a lot
denser you can see it's only it's half
the mass but it's much less than half of
the volume right because the volume is
with the cube of the radius and all of
that i don't want to confuse you but
this is just something to think about so
not only does the mass matter but the
radius matters a lot we and the radius
is actually the square so it actually
matters even more
so that's that's uh something that's
that's pretty interesting to think about
and these are actually very common
problems um when they just you know they
want to tell you oh you go to a planet
that is two times the mass of another
planet et cetera et cetera what is the
uh you know what is the difference in
force between the two and one thing i
want you to realize actually before i
finish this video since i do have some
extra time
when we think about gravity especially
with planets and all of that
you always feel like oh it's earth
pulling on me
you always feel like let's say that this
is the earth
and the earth is huge
and this is you know let's say this is a
tiny spaceship right here you know
it's
it's traveling
you always think that earth is pulling
on the spaceship right the gravitational
force of earth but actually turns out
you know we when we looked at the
formula
it's a formula symmetric it's not really
saying one is pulling on the other
they're actually saying this is the
force between the two objects they're
attracted to each other so if the earth
is pulling on me with the force of um i
don't know would
if the force is if the earth is pulling
on me with the force of 500 newtons it
actually turns out that i am pulling on
the earth with an equal and opposite
force of five units we're pulling
towards each other it just feels like
the the earth is at least from my point
of view that the earth is is pulling to
me and we're actually
both being pulled towards the combined
center of mass so in this situation
let's say the earth is pulling on this
spaceship
with the force of oh i don't know i i'm
i'm making up numbers now but let's say
it's a million newtons
one million newtons it actually turns
out that the spaceship will be pulling
on the earth
with the same force of one million
newtons
and they're both going to be moved to
their center of the combined system
center of mass and the combined system
center of mass since the earth is so
much more massive is going to be very
close to earth's center of mass it's
probably going to be
very close to earth's center mass gonna
be like right there right so
in this situation
earth won't be doing a lot of moving
but it will be pulled in the direction
of the spaceship and the spaceship will
try to go to earth's center of mass but
at some point probably the atmosphere or
the rock that it runs into it won't be
able to to go much further and it might
crash right around there but anyway i
want to just give you the sense that
it's not necessarily one object just
pulling on the other they're pulling
towards each other to their combined
center of masses and it would make a lot
more sense if you know if we you know if
they had just two people floating in
space they actually would have some
gravity towards each other it's almost a
little romantic
they would they would float to each
other and actually you could figure it
out on the you know the the
i don't have the time to do it but you
could use this formula and figure out to
use the constant and you can figure out
well what is the gravitational
attraction between two people and what
you'll see is that between two people
floating in space
there are other forms of attraction that
are probably stronger than their their
gravitational attraction anyway i'll let
you ponder that and i will see you in
the next video